these pictures of russian military on
the streets of hassan were filmed in the
last few days
over recent weeks we've spoken to
residents still stuck there and
ukrainians who've managed to escape
we've been sent videos and photographs
filmed in secret and given to us over
encrypted networks
at huge personal risk to themselves and
their families they tell a story of a
city living in fear
trying to reach anyone still inside
hassan is extremely hard after weeks of
trying we made contact with dimitro it's
not his real name and he spoke to us
from hiding
[Music]
off from the outside world now there is
barely any mobile or internet connection
most people are also understandably too
scared to talk
this park is one of the only places in
the city where they can still get a
ukrainian phone signal ukrainian phone
networks have been shut down and
replaced with bugged russian lines
simply meeting friends takes courage
[Music]
[Music]
these signs warn residents that only
russian credit cards now accepted
any sign of old ukrainian life is being
erased
the price of meat imported from russia
is so astronomical that people have to
live off a diet of vegetables now
medicine is now in desperately short
supply and is sold on the streets at
makeshift stalls
the lucky few who have managed to escape
hess on head for odessa around the coast
we met lilia at a refugee center in the
city
of
a resistance newspaper has been launched
to keep morale up in the city it is
pushed through letterboxes after dark
leaflets have been printed warning
people not to apply for russian
passports
and a private ukrainian resistance
network inside the city keeps people
updated with the location of russian
checkpoints
the ukrainian colours are painted on
walls around the city in defiance it's
incredibly dangerous though we've been
told stories of people taken to
basements and electrocuted just for
displaying the ukrainian flag
we can't independently verify these
accounts and the russians deny the
claims but we've heard them from
multiple sources over the course of many
months
[Music]
in recent weeks the ukrainian military
has strategically bombed the three
bridges that cross the dinipro river
they are now virtually impassable to
heavy vehicles
this is cutting off crucial russian
resupply routes and leaving the
remaining russian soldiers inside hesson
vulnerable
with the bridges out of action there is
now a boat to ferry people across the
river
this is also pretty much the only way
the russians can cross it now too
if they can't repair the bridges they
surely cannot hold out for long
in recent days russian soldiers have
been breaking into garages searching for
ukrainian weapons
they seem to be spooked by rumors of an
imminent ukrainian counter-offensive
for those still trapped inside hesson
that counter-offensive cannot come soon
enough